- Hello, and welcome to
Ed Talks with Khan Academy
where we talk to influential people
in the field of education.
I am excited today to talk
with Dr. Dan Willingham.
Before we get started with that
I want to remind all of
you that Khan Academy
is a non-profit that relies
on donations from folks like yourself to
help us help keep more people learning
and you can find the space
to donate there on our site.
Also during the pandemic
we have required some extra
supports to help keep us going
and make sure
that all learners have
those opportunities that
they've needed for digital
learning in this time.
And we want to particularly
thank Bank of America,
AT&T, Google.org, Novartis,
Fastly, and General Motors
for their support.
Thankful for all of
that, all of that help.
And finally we want to
remind you that there's
an audio version of our
ED Talks that's available.
Homeroom With Sal, the
podcast, available wherever
you get your podcasts.
So, take a look at that.
You can find previous
episodes and review favorites
while you're looking for those.
So today as I said, I'm excited to talk to
Dr. Dan Willingham.
When people ask me, hey
where can I read more
about learning science
and how people learn,
his book, "Why Don't Students Like School"
is one of the first
places I send people to.
And the second edition of
that book is out this week.
So go find that at your
favorite book seller.
And in addition to all
the previous content
it also covers educational technology,
which of course is a place
that is near and dear
to my heart.
But Dan, welcome and
thanks for joining us.
- Hi Kristen, I'm so glad to be here,
and thanks for having me.
- Absolutely.
So, I want to as usual in these talks,
start off with some
questions that I have from
reading your works, and then we'll go
to audience questions.
So those of you who are listening
feel free to add things and questions into
the chat and I will pick those up as well.
But I'm interested in
starting and thinking
about curiosity, which is
something that you talk
about upfront in one
of your first chapters,
and thinking about there's
things that it seems
like we're curious about
and there's some natural
curiosity when you think about young kids
asking questions and where that is,
but then sometimes it
seems to kind of fade away
and there's like, we kind
of lose some of that.
So, how should we think about curiosity in
helping us learn?
- So, yeah curiosity is one of the things
that I just find so fascinating because
I notice this in myself
before I was a cognitive psychologist
or studied any of these things formally.
We think of curiosity of
being driven by content.
So, you think like, I'm
a cognitive psychologist,
so I'm curious about cognitive psychology.
And the truth is like that's sort of true,
but not remotely true as a general rule.
I have been to many many
conferences and attended
cognitive psychology talks
and found myself extraordinarily bored.
And I'm sure everybody
listening to this talk now
has had the same experience.
You go into something,
you start reading a book,
or you watch a YouTube
video 'cause you're like,
oh I love this topic.
This is gonna be great.
And then it's horrible.
And then the opposite can
equally happen equally often
where somebody sort of
forces you to watch a YouTube
video about how they make
dumbbells and you're like,
that can't be interesting.
And then oh my god, it's
totally fascinating.
So I think the through line for curiosity,
you mentioned kids and how
kids seem to be curious
about everything, and then
like we adults not so much.
We're much more selective.
The kind of through
line for that I think is
curiosity is all about learning
about your environment.
And so we are continually
sizing up our environment and
figuring out is this,
is there an opportunity
for learning here?
And learning the way you
make that calculation is
the unknown needs to be at
sort of just the right level.
So, if you offer me some information,
and it's a topic, like if you said to me,
"Hey, would you like to
know who the first president
of the U.S. is?"
I'm like, that doesn't
make be very curious,
because I already have
that information, right.
Likewise, if you said, would
you like to know who the first
president of Chad was, I'm like sort of.
But I really don't know
anything about Chad,
and so that's not gonna help me very much.
It's when there's
information that's gonna add
to what we already know,
that seems to be a really
critical trigger for curiosity.
And that helps us understand
why small children are
curious about everything.
They don't know anything.
So they are well positioned
to be sponges and be
curious about everything
because the world is
offering all this information
and they don't know
anything about the world.
- That's great.
So, as you said, you're
a cognitive psychologist
and a professor of psychology.
What was your path to getting
to that place in your career.
How did you come to be a
cognitive psychologist?
- I came to be a, it was
much a matter of curiosity.
Both of my parents were
actually psychologists,
neither one of them a
cognitive psychologist.
But they both had degrees
in experimental psychology.
My dad went off and
became a psychometrician,
my mother later became a counselor.
And my uncle was also an
experimental psychologist.
So I was really determined
not to do anything
in psychology at all.
But then in college I thought
gosh, I guess I need to take
like intro to psychology
or something so that
I can keep up at Thanksgiving dinner.
So I did and I found myself
absolutely fascinated.
And then I started taking
a broader array of courses
and cognitive psychology just really,
I want to say, caught my
fancy, which is a weird
turn of phrase, but that
pretty well describes it.
I just couldn't get enough of it,
and so decided to go
to graduate school and
just keep doing what I loved.
- That's great.
And I love the, I don't want
anything to do with what
my parents did, but oh that's actually
kind of interesting too.
Yeah, absolutely.
So thinking generally across
your education experience
were there any particularly
teachers who influenced
you or that you found really
helped you on your path?
- Oh my gosh.
I had so many amazing teachers.
I mentioned that I was
really captivated by
cognitive psychology in college.
And Ruth Day was the professor
who taught that course.
And I took the psychology
of language course
afterwards with her.
I did a senior thesis with her.
So she was certainly extremely influential
in developing my love of psychology.
I also have to single out
my fifth grade teacher,
Richard Leewer, who was just a really
really inspiring teacher and
really made me come to school
excited to learn every day
and also really managed
to help me see that school
was something I was doing for myself.
I think up until that point,
I kind of went to school just
because like you're a kid
and that's what you do.
And like, to the extent
that I had any skin
in the game, so to speak
it was like I was doing this
to make my parents happy.
Like if, if I didn't go, my
parents would be mad at me.
And Mr. Leewer actually really made me see
that learning was something that was fun
and something that I
appreciated and something
I benefited from.
So, you know, I couldn't tell you exactly
what content I learned
in fifth grade from him
but I will never forget
that sort of attitude
towards school and that
attitude towards learning.
- That's great.
Actually, when people ask
me about teachers, myself
and my fifth grade teacher
was also very influential
in what we did.
So I wonder too
if there's something about that
age, that that gets people.
So do you, we were talking about how
that kind of inspiration,
but also building
on what you learned and what
you know and where those are.
So there's a lot of
we talk about in motivation,
finding meaning for learning.
And one of the things
that can help motivate
students is finding meaning
in what they're doing.
And I know lots of
teachers get the question
of what am I going to use this?
Why do I need this?
How should we help build meaning?
And what do we do when it seems
like the things that we need to learn
don't have a lot of meaning?
- Yeah, I mean, I comment
on this a little bit
in "Why Don't Students Like
School" and in a way it's a
stance that concerns me a little bit.
I don't feel
like will students find
this meaningful now is
a very good litmus test to
which we should hold content.
And the reason for that
is I think there's a lot
of things that students
will enjoy knowing,
will find beautiful, will
maybe even find important
that they don't find
meaningful in their life
as they would describe it.
In other words, if you try
and tempt them with, look
this is something that is
important for you to know
and you're going to find it interesting
and important in your daily life.
I think, first of all
I think a lot of times that's going to be
feel really strained for
us because a lot of what we
as adults kind of in
our more mature judgment
think this is important for a
fifth grader to learn about.
It's not immediately obvious
to the fifth grader that yes
that's going to be meaningful to me.
But in contrast, we can, we
were talking about curiosity.
You can make people curious
about things to say like, look
here's this puzzle, here's
this odd, here's this fact
in mathematics, like how,
why is it work that way?
Or here's this fact in science?
Why, what is that all about?
I think that's a more
when we're talking about motivation, yes.
Things seeming personally
meaningful, personally relevant
to me that can be powerful
but I think that will
greatly narrow the scope
of what it is we want
students to know about.
Also worry a little bit candidly, that it
it sends an implicit message
that the students are kind
of in the driver's seat.
In other words, if I'm continually
trying to show students
this is meaningful to
you, this is meaningful.
That also sort of implies the contra,
the counterpoint that, well
if I don't think it's meaningful
then that maybe means I
shouldn't be learning it.
And I, I don't think
that fifth graders
should have that control.
I think that teachers are
the ones who should be
deciding this is what's important
for you to learn right now.
And it's incumbent on me to
make you intrigued about it.
- Interesting, so I
just, as you were talking
had this thought, as
you said that about them
that deciding it, also triggered
in me some of the conversations
around diversity and
inclusion and that just
because it's not relevant to
me, let's say the, you know
upper middle-class white fifth grader
in the suburban school, doesn't mean
that it's not something
that I should know to
be able to understand the experiences
of other people too, and where that is.
So I wonder if there's a link there.
- I agree.
I mean, I think that's
especially point, not poignant,
but it's especially important
to consider in the realm
of human experience to so,
so to sort of say, like
what do I have to learn about this story
that's about somebody
who's totally unlike me?
Like, no, that's kind of the point is
first of all, it's interesting
and important to learn
about the perspectives
of people from other cultures,
people who are not like you.
And second of all,
you're gonna see some
similarities that maybe
you didn't expect,
that there is universality
in the human experience.
And how are you going to know that
unless you read about some people
who are different than you are?
- Yeah, absolutely fascinating.
I do want to get a little bit
to talking about in the
realm of technology.
So in COVID and we've, you know
even more started relying on
digital learning environments.
And one of the things that
we hear sometimes is are all
of these phones and screens changing
how people learn are
they getting different
dopamine hits?
Are our attention spans changing?
What are your thoughts on that?
- Well, there's a lot of pieces, you know
just in your question,
right, there was really
like three different ones in
there about whether, you know
are screens changing our brains?
Do we learn?
Let's take those two questions.
Are screens changing our brains?
And then do we learn
differently from screens?
The idea that screens are
changing our brains, I've argued
that's very improbable.
And the reason I argue that,
the main way that people have suspected
that screens are changing our brains is
that they are reducing
attention span and/or
reducing working memory span.
First of all, we have data
that that's not happening.
So there are certain tests
of working memory that
had been administered
for close to a hundred years.
And so we actually have data
from limited populations, not
you know, worldwide or anything
but we certainly have American samples.
And we know that working memory span just
hasn't changed with
the digital revolution.
So actually data on that.
And then also from a
theoretical perspective
you just wouldn't expect,
the brain is plastic.
This is frequently what you
hear, the brain is plastic.
And so how could it not
change in response to the
all this experience with screens?
And what I would say to
that is the brain is plastic
but it can't be that plastic.
So take working memory in particular.
There are so many cognitive
processes that depend
on working memory, reading,
problem solving, mathematics,
all the things we care
about in school basically,
really depend on working memory capacity.
So if working memory
capacity were really plastic
and really change with the environment
and it shrunk the impact would cascade
throughout the cognitive system.
And basically everybody
would be really stupid
if working memory capacity,
shrunk significantly.
Now in terms of whether or
not we learn differently
from screens, it's
pretty clear that we do.
And just think about Zoom fatigue.
That's enough to start to with, I mean
this is what everybody is
found during the pandemic.
The signal that you're getting
from a screen is not as rich
as the signal that you get
from a live human being.
And so one of the ways you're dealing
with that is your expending
more cognitive effort
trying to make up for that signal.
The, you know, you don't, for one thing
you frequently don't have gestures.
You can occasionally see,
I sort of self-consciously
I'm trying to keep my hands up here.
So you can getting a little
bit more signal from that.
Frequently though, you know,
you're looking at a talking head,
you're not getting any gestures.
The two dimensionality
obviously makes a difference.
The, you get a lag.
There's all these problems with screens.
And so what the viewer is doing is they're
expending more cognitive energy
trying to extract everything
they can from that signal.
So learning from screens
in there when, little kids
are not very good at this.
Little kids really have
problems with screens.
And if you Google the term video deficit
you can find some of this, some
of this research literature.
So certainly you can learn from screens
but it's not the same experience.
And we've made enormous
strides in the last 10
or 15 years in figuring out
how to do this effectively
but there are still issues
that we're trying to overcome.
- Yeah, absolutely.
So do you have recommendations
about, you know,
screen time and the amounts
of how much should parents
or teachers be thinking
about the amount of time
students are spending on screens?
- I mean like most people I'm, you know
I'm very quick to say,
well it depends on what
they're doing on their screens.
But the truth is like
if your child is unsupervised,
when they're, you know
have a laptop or have an iPad or something
you kind of know what they're doing.
It's not, they're not looking
at Shakespeare Concordances.
There are data on this that they're
they're mostly consuming video content.
They're texting their friends.
I mean, the way I put it in
"Why Students Don't Like School"
is they're basically doing the stuff
that kids have always liked to do.
And they're just doing it with technology.
Now, when I was left to my own devices
when I was nine years old,
when I was 15 years old
I was mostly not doing
the most enriching things.
And so it's really less
about like, you know,
what do you want your kids to be doing?
Is it really the screen per se?
Or is it that, gosh, I wish
they were reading, you know
reading more books,
or I wish they were
reading more non-fiction,
or I wish they were working
on their social skills more,
whatever it is, whatever
it is you want them to do
they can probably do it on a screen.
They could probably do it off a screen.
So you need to figure
out how you're going to
encourage your child to engage
in more of the activities they want.
I think the thing that really bugs people
about screen time is spend times mostly
on supervised and yeah, most
of what kids do when they're
unsupervised on screens is
you know, in the long
run, not super enriching.
It's kind of fun for them,
but not very enriching.
I have to say (audio distorting)
this is especially
acute with the pandemic.
Like most parents, we had
lots of rules in my house
and then the pandemic
struck and my wife and I
are like, just play Among Us all you want.
Whatever it is, this has
just been a nightmare
for everybody, like, you
know, I can't blame you.
Just do whatever you want to do.
We're trying to (cross talking).
- Absolutely, absolutely.
So we talked about screens.
There's actually a comment from YouTube,
Bencat Parkenen who says that more audio
learning should be implemented.
I never use audio learning
in my high school,
but it's so much powerful now.
And so I wonder if do
you have thoughts about
how learning is impacted
by different communication
methods or channels?
- Yeah, I mean that's been
pretty carefully researched
when it comes to reading.
So the comparison being
reading text versus listening
to an audiobook.
I don't know that there's
been a lot of research on
audio learning more broadly.
There's a whole lot of, so I'll comment on
reading from print versus an audio book.
There's a whole lot of overlap
in the mental machinery
that comprehends printed text versus
listening the to someone
read the same text.
This is assuming that
you are a very smooth
fluent decoder when you are reading print.
So in other words, going
from print on the page
to words in the mind
is no problem for you.
You're quite fassel with that.
If you are there's a whole
lot of overlap between
the two processes.
Because the processes
that you use to comprehend
written text is basically the same process
you use for oral language.
There's some differences
around the margins,
which are not trivial.
One that's pretty obvious
is that when you're
listening to a book
someone's reading it to you.
And so you get what scientists
call prosodic information.
Prosidy is sort of
music of speech and it's
what tells you the difference
between what a great party
and what a great party, right.
So sarcasm is all a matter of prosity.
And so in that sense listening
to a text is a little bit
easier because the, whoever
is doing the reading
is giving you that prosodic information.
On the other hand when
you're reading print
it's very easy to move
backwards in a text.
You control the pace you can
read as quickly and slowly
as you want and it's real
easy to go backwards.
And if you look at eye
movements while people
are reading something like 10,
15% of eye movements are
actually regressions where you're
going back.
You had a little bit of trouble unraveling
the syntax of a sentence
maybe so you go back to
pick up a few words.
In principle you can go
back when you're listening
to an audiobook.
But in practice it's kind
of awkward and most people
don't really do it.
And of course you're not in
terrific control of the pace.
So that makes audiobooks
slightly more difficult.
So again, lots and lots
of overlap, but the,
some differences at the margins.
- Got it. Thank you.
We've got a few more questions
coming in on Facebook.
So, one of the things we keep hearing
and Shelly Acosta Thompson asks a question
related to that now is
how do you keep teens motivated,
especially this year, but
over time it seems to be
an ongoing question of how
we keep them interested
in wanting to learn.
- Yeah, how we keep students
interested in school.
- Particularly teens, but yes.
- Particularly teens, yeah,
and I don't know whether the
question is really like from
a parental perspective versus
from a teacher's perspective.
- It is, she has a 14 year old.
- So it's from a parental perspective.
Yeah, I mean it gets difficult
because lots of other things
crowd around in on their time.
And teens in particular
are become extraordinarily
interested in their social lives.
BJ Casey is a psychologist
at Yale University,
has a very good take on this I think.
She points out that this
is practice for them,
this is preparation for
becoming independent
of their parents.
So they're becoming extremely
attuned to their peers
because they're now
learning how to navigate
this world where other
people are going to be
important as they move out of their home.
So, I that kind of
competition, trig just does not
seem to hold a whole lot of appeal.
I think one of the things
that is important to do,
and it's certainly not gonna
be a full blown solution,
is to emphasis that this is a family value
and I hope that this is
something that has been
a family value all along.
And so sort of acknowledge and validate
like I get it that there are other things
you're interested in, I also get it.
Mr. Willingham, your history
teacher is pretty boring.
That's legit. I'm not
saying that he's not.
At the same time some
things have not changed.
And one of the things
that hasn't changed is
in this family we take school seriously.
We show up on time.
We are, talk politely to our teachers,
all the sorts of things that
you've been doing all along
are important and
continue to be important.
And one of the things that continues
to be important is trying
your best in all your classes
and making sure that
you make time for that.
So, in general I'm very
much a fan of trying to
start with positivity and trying to start
with sort of appealing to the best
in sort of a teen's sense of self,
like start saying, this is who you are.
This is the best version
of you that you want to be.
You want to be the kind of, or you are the
kind of person who treats school this way.
As opposed to the punitive
approach, like well look,
if you're not gonna do you work then I'm
gonna take your iPad away.
Because that's obviously not appealing
to the best in the student.
And I also find that tit
ends up being a little bit
of a game of cat and mouse.
It's sort of like, well,
you're not doing what I want
you to do therefore I'm
gonna do this to you.
And that to me sort of sets up a bargain
in the child's mind.
Like, okay, so if I can
still get away with not doing
what you want me to do and retain my iPad
then I'm kind of winning.
Whereas if I'm appealing
to their sense of self
then they themselves kind of know whether
or not they're living up to that.
So, if I can do it that's
gonna be my starting place.
- Got it. Thank you.
And I know that's a whole
how to motivate teens
could be a whole series of books.
- Oh god, god help us all.
I mean that's, as the father
of two teens right now
this is a very difficult problem.
I feel your pain for sure.
- Definitely, definitely.
So, in thinking about motivation,
you know we talked
earlier about curiosity.
I wonder if there's something too with,
that really thinking about
motivation, curiosity
and I know you talked
recently about creativity too
and if there's appealing
to students creativity
or opportunities there
to encourage students
into being interested in learning.
- I think absolutely.
And this is something that
I think most parents want
to do this and I think
most parents are doing it
as much as they can, but
encouraging creative outlets
that are not necessarily part of school
I think is a wonderful opportunity to keep
kids engaged with
learning, especially kids
who are struggling in a lot
of their school subjects.
That feeling that because
what you're really worried
about and trying to
guard against is a sense
of self that doesn't
include learning at all.
It's sort of like, well,
school is not a place where
I succeed.
School is not a place where
I feel good about myself
and so that sort of extends to any type of
learning that might happen, period, right.
Because school is where you learn.
In contrast to if a
student can feel like yeah,
the stuff I do at school I
really struggle with that.
That's really hard for me.
I'm not sure I see that
in my future long term.
But then there's this
other content that I feel
really passionate about.
I know I'm good at that and that entails
learning and I'm good
at that type of learning
that seems like a really
desirable way to go.
And it doesn't, obviously
it doesn't just apply
to students who are struggling in school.
This is, you know, having
that passion, especially
feeling like they can
go deep on something.
One of the things I know is so frustrating
for students is everything
is sort of a million
miles wide and two inches deep.
And so getting to the
point where they feel like
they're really getting mastery.
And they know more about
this than most adults do.
That's like, that's
really exciting for them.
And every kid deserves to feel that way.
- Absolutely, that seems like a good note.
The half hour has flown by.
So we will wrap it up there.
Thank you so much for your time today.
Again folks, Dr. Dan Willingham.
Check out the second edition of his book
that's out now and the, we'll remind
all of you as well that
tomorrow at the same
time we have Ben Gomes who will be talking
about new learning initiatives at Google.
So you can join us then.
Thanks again to Dr. Dan
Willingham for joining us.
All of you have a good day
and we will see you next time.
(logo chiming)